hi in this video i'm going to talk about
role of prb
protein rb and rb stands for
retinoblastoma in cell cycle control so
role of prb in a cell cycle control so
we need to understand why prp is
important and why we should study about
prb and its role in cell cycle control
so in normal cell prb prevents the cell
cycle progression until and unless it's
phosphorylated by cyclin d and cdk4 so
in normal cases prb prevents cell cycle
progression
so prb could be thought as a tumor
suppressor because prb actually prevents
the cell cycle progression so it
prevents
unpredicted growth or
uncontrolled growth so prb is good in
this sense and it's a
tumor suppressor protein
so prb
is
actually function like
so prb
usually
inhibits e to f and what is e to f
e to f it's uh essential
protein which actually helps in the
further stages of the cell cycle control
and it's actually help to transcribe
other target proteins which are
necessary for s phase
of the cell cycle so prb actually
inhibits e2f
by binding with e2f
and
when
in the late
g1 phase
prb would be phosphorylated by a complex
of cyclin d and cdk4 r6 and now the
phosphorylated prb
would uh no longer hold e2f and e2f is
free to function free to function and
now what happened e2f
would transcribe gene that are required
for cell division
and
let's see
how
cyclin d is activated uh how once from
one side mitogenic signal is coming and
how
from one side uh prb is actually
in uh inhibiting the cell cycle
before uh this particular point of the g
led g1 phase is called r point
prb
would hold e to f and won't allow e2f to
do its function
so this is
before the r point after the r point
there is
our point is also known as restriction
point after the r point inside the cell
there would be a lot of cyclin d and cdk
complex so this complex can
phosphorylated prp and when prb is
phosphorylated it's no longer functional
and it cannot hold e2f and e2f can go
into the nucleus and transcribe other
genes that are required for
the other stages of the cell cycle so
in the early g1 phase a lot of mitogenic
signal
appears in the cell and from the
receptor tyrosine kinase
in the receptor tyrosine kinase mediated
way map kinase signaling happens and the
target for these mitogens are actually
the cyclin d1 so when cyclin d is
produced
cdk and cdk4 and cycling d complex is
activated and beyond our point
these
prb is inhibited
when a cyclin d1 and cdk4 complex
phosphorylates prb
and e2f can
perform its function now cell cycle can
go from lead g1 to s and then g2 to m so
cell cycle progression can happen
so
in this respect prb is important now if
there is a mutation in prb it may lead
to cancer because
prb's main function is to hold the cell
cycle progression before the
the cell reaches the restriction point
after the cell reaches a restriction
point
prb would allow
the e2f to do its function and the cell
cycle
progression would be resumed but
there is should be a balanced manner
how much prb would be present in a cell
so if prb amount is less or prb is
mutant that means prb is not functional
then prb can hold e to f
and
when we don't want cell division
to take place
then then even cell division can take
place uh that happens in the cancer cell
so prb does not
uh
inhibit e2a e2f in the cancer cells so
cancer cells divide divide and divide
in an uncontrolled manner and
thus they proliferate in an uncontrolled
manner
that is why prb is very important
and
in cancers what happens that cyclin
de-overexpression takes place that means
a lot of mitogenic signals ultimately
leads to production of over production
of cycling d1 when cycling d1 is
overproduced this cyclin d1 and cdk46
complex can actually phosphorylate prp
and when prb is phosphorylated it's no
more functional and e2f can
do its job and the cell cycle
progression can occur so suppose in a
normal cell we don't want the cell to
divide at this condition at now but if
the prb is
mutated in that particular cell
so the control over the cell cycle would
be lost and the cell would divide in an
uncontrolled manner which would
ultimately lead to tumor formation and
thus cancer so that is why
prb
is very important in cell cycle control
and regulating the cell cycle control
i hope you enjoyed this video please
like and subscribe for latest video
thank you